amy is with us in Dallas Texas hi Amy
how are you hi can you thanks for taking
my call
sure what's up I inherited a leased
vehicle and an expected divorce at what
point does that make sense for me to
finish out the lease payments and then
purchase the vehicle at the end of the
lease oh wow what a mess how much how
much is left on the lease how long how
much how only much length
how many months six eight eighty five to
buy it out today and I have thirty two
months at 477 a month and if I turn it
in today I'm upside down 9855 you're
upside down by the dealers equation yes
okay so that's it because I went to
Carmack's and got a bid and they'll only
give me seventeen so if I turn it in
writing
okay but but the Carmack's bid is
obviously a wholesale bid and so that
means you're probably in the hole more
like six thousand okay
maybe seven thousand something like that
okay and you inherited this is in your
name it is now it was ordered that I had
to pay it off and I didn't have the
money to pay it off when the divorce
went through so they put it in finding
and I assumed put it into your name then
the leasing agency although it's a third
party leasing agency it's not directly
with and so they took they took your
ex-husband off the lease and put you on
it yeah - release him / the divorce
decree okay highly unusual but
interesting alright so for how what is
your income my income with child support
is only at the moment nineteen hundred a
month and I live with my parents with my
two girls good lord
yeah okay how do you end up with this
car you must have a really bad lawyer
[Music]
yeah it yeah so okay all right so bottom
line is 1,900 bucks from now which is
477 times 32 I didn't do that right no
that's 15,000 bucks I'm sorry $15,000 if
you keep the car what condition is your
credit in fantastic I have 800 score
how much other we think agency said to
me was we could roll some of that into a
new car as soon as I said how much can
you afford for a month I'd like to say
Ramsey but don't do that yeah yeah that
doesn't help you okay yeah let's pretend
that you sold the car today
not for 17,000 to car max but to an
individual for 19 okay okay and you
borrowed the difference from your local
credit union okay okay there's two
options or there's three options here
option number one is you pay for 77
times 32 which is 15,000 bucks to keep
to keep the car till the end of the
lease and then buy the car at the end of
the lease you can't afford this car I
don't at any point in this so keeping
the car doesn't make sense on a monthly
basis 477 as a percentage of your income
is nuts
and keeping the car long-term doesn't
make sense
so make sense long term because you
can't afford it right yes it's it's a
ridiculous amount of money given your
income and so what I would rather you
have is a very very inexpensive car a
hoopty 2 or $3,000 car and a small loan
of six or seven thousand dollars to
cover the difference on this okay that's
going to put you way ahead of where you
are now or way ahead of where you would
be if you kept the car till the end the
lease and tried to buy it out so what I
would start working on is a local bank
or
local credit union loan unsecured loan
for the difference of what the car will
actually sell for not to a dealer we're
not in desperation mode yet
I mean you drive it and pay the payments
for a little while and let's just try to
get it sold for more than Carmack's
they'll give you for it and it's not the
car max is evil they're not doing
anything wrong
they're just in the business of selling
cars for a profit which means they have
to buy them in wholesale and sell them
for retail I want you instead to sell it
to go on Kelly Blue Book kbb.com and
look at private sale price and I think
you'll see that I'm right that this is a
it's a couple grand more than car max is
offering you probably what kind of car
is it sound like three yes three hundred
hybrid okay good it'll sell then okay
okay so you just put it on like
Craigslist or something like that and
start an auto trade or that kind of
thing and start selling it to an
individual and let an individual buy it
cheaper than they can buy it from a
dealer but a whole lot more than a
dealer will give you for it okay and
then you have to have a loan for the
difference to get out of this but
instead of twenty six thousand eight
hundred eighty five dollar debt then you
got a six thousand dollar debt that just
sounds a lot better in your situation to
me yes and my tax return will actually
cover if it's only six or seven thousand
dollars and my tax return can cover that
and I won't have to take out a loan okay
cool so you're getting a tax return of
six thousand bucks
yeah but you said you made $1,900 a
month I did the tax credit Wow how many
kids you got - okay how old are you 45
okay I'm gonna stay at home mom forever
and so I'm trying to get out in life
yeah yeah you got a reset for sure you
have a new normal I'm sure that is good
he's in the detail oh he is in the
details you're fighting through it
you're you're a warrior kiddo well
you're you're gonna be fine
you're gonna be fine yeah that's what I
would do I would dump this car and are
sell it I wouldn't dump it but I would
sell it and I'd rather you have that you
know use your tax return for that and
then let's get you a little get around
car and then when you get yourself
reinvented and your income comes on up
because it's going to one year from
today life looks completely different
than it does today you know that yeah
and so once you get this career path
going and you get plugged back in your
income is going to double pretty quick
probably and as it does then you can
move up in car for cash as you go along
is this the only debt you inherited in
this mess I have a house in another
state and it's got a lantern in it so
it's paying for itself right now and the
extra money that comes from that rent is
going on six months set aside in case
the renter's not there you have you have
six months so you've got the cash there
too yes I technically could I just
Financial Peace University said I didn't
want to touch that because I wanted to
have the six months towards if the
renter's not there don't leave that
house I completely agree with that and
then I completely agree with selling
that house as soon as that lease is up
but in the interim if you need two
thousand dollars of that money to buy
you a car or something then rather than
you know some of these other things
we're talking about that gets you out of
this and and get you going in the other
direction yeah if you're unless you're
moving into that house you need to sell
it at the end of that lease and so good
well that's some extra cash lay in there
too so you got two ways to get out of
this money-wise and I don't want you to
drain that dry and leave yourself
vulnerable permanently but right now
you're pretty vulnerable with a twenty
six thousand eight hundred eighty five
dollar card debt so we got to clear that
by getting it sold covering the
difference let's sell it for as much as
we can possibly sew it for get you a
little paid for car and we'll reset
restart life hey thanks for the call I'm
sorry you're going through this
what a mess this is the Dave Ramsey show